des civils tués alors qu'ils cherchaient
à fuir en train ils répondaient à
l'appel d'évacuation des autorités
ukrainiennes des femmes et des enfants
surtout à qui l'on avait dit partez
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard les
autorités ukrainiennes n'ont pas pu
éviter le cauchemar qu'il redoutait deux
missiles se sont abattus sur la gare de
tram à tort ce bilan une cinquantaine de
morts et plus d'une centaine de blessés
la veille alors que la population se
massaient devant la gare pour quitter
l'est du pays les rails avait été
endommagé par une frappe trois trains
s'étaient retrouvés bloqués en soit ce
n'était rien d'inhabituel depuis le
début de la guerre ce matin-là alexander
camille chine s'était demandé s'il
n'était pas justement trop tard pour
continuer les évacuations
mon autre
on surveille tout constamment nous avons
des gérants locaux très compétent d'un
chat gars quand il se passe quelque
chose nous le savons tout de suite c'est
le réseau le plus stable au monde si on
ne veut pas aller sur ses rails on n'y
va pas nous les répare on est ensuite
nous y allons
s'il ne peut plus se targuer de faire
rouler les trains à l'heure alexander
camille chine peut au moins se dire
qu'il a su garder le pays sur les rails
depuis le début de la guerre le réseau
ferroviaire est devenue une véritable
ligne de vie pour l'ukraine
toutes les grandes villes sont encore
desservies nous avons perdu le contrôle
temporairement d'environ 20% de nos
infrastructures
pour le reste ils nous bombardent nous
réparons il continue de nous bombarder
et nous continuons de réparer oui
il n'a pas quitté la gare depuis le
début de la guerre sauf pour se déplacer
en train d'une gare à l'autre chaque
jour il faut revoir la carte du pays
évaluées skie toujours accessible ce qui
est maintenant hors d'accès sous le
contrôle des russes au plus fort des
opérations d'évacuation deux cent mille
personnes sont montées à bord tous les
jours la compagnie ferroviaire emploie
près de 230 mille employés et la très
grande majorité est restée en poste
depuis le début de hier ce qui a coûté
la vie à 70 d'entre eux mais c'est un
devoir d'y pétro-t tube le chef de la
gare de kiev qu est ce que je
sache que ça peut les voir c'est très
difficile de vivre ce que nous vivons en
ce moment c'est une période sombre de
nos vies c'est difficile de voir les
gens surtout les enfants qui souffrent
même si nous ne transportons pas les
passagers sous les bombardements nous
voyons leur terreur leurs inquiétudes
c'est très dur à voir
il y à la peur la panique et les adieux
déchirants qui se répètent de quai en
quai les femmes et les enfants sont
transportés gratuitement en priorité les
hommes eux doivent rester pour défendre
le pays
à
sa femme comme toutes les autres
ukrainiennes sont bien plus forte qu'on
ne le croit dit sergueï mais ce n'est
plus possible de prendre un risque avec
les russes ce sont des chiens enragés
dit-il de kent
cheng
et you
back in the next few
à bord du train irina a déjà pris place
le souffle court elle regrette la
séparation forcée de son mari qu'elle
avait repoussé jusqu'au dernier instant
elle est montée à bord à zaporizhya avec
ses trois enfants et leurs deux petits
chiens direction d'abord les vivent près
de la frontière polonaise après c'est
une europe inconnu qui les attend le
voyage sera long par mesure de sécurité
la vitesse de tous les trains a été
réduite de moitié à 60 kilomètres/heure
en cas d'explosion en route on espère
ainsi pouvoir sauver au moins certains
des passagers
pris au départ nous avions un train qui
transportait trois cents personnes par
jour en pologne en temps de paix et
maintenant nous en transportant dix
mille certains jours et nous pensons la
frontière à quatre endroits
à l'ouest les wagons sont remplies dead
humanitaire qui feront le chemin inverse
ce pour être distribué partout au pays
avant la reprise des évacuations de
masse de l'est de l'ukraine vers l'ouest
de la semaine dernière une pause avait
permis aux responsables des chemins de
fer de se concentrer sur une phase
secondaire de la refonte de leurs
opérations tout aussi essentielle avec
les ports du pays complètement
inaccessible c'est au train que revient
maintenant l'essentiel des importations
et des exportations a dans la guerre
l'ukraine pouvait exporter jusqu'à 7
millions de tonnes de céréales par
bateau le train lui ne peut en
transporter qu'un million
nous ne pouvons transporter que
billington pour l'est il faut augmenter
la capacité surfant sur vocal tourner
une clause d'occupation tout est une
question de survie croit alexandre il
faut bien dit-il s'assurer qu'il reste
encore une raison de demeurer en ukraine
après la guerre jeune chef de réseau
ferroviaire ne peut pas se résoudre à
n'être que l'architecte de l'exil
ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada kiev